we really had to like produce an actual
event and then shoot at it
I quit hey everybody welcome to the
other show I'm Sarah and I'm Chris and
we're here talking about Episode two of
the other two withdrew and Hellena this
episode is chase goes to a premiere hey
cuties I'm about to hit the red carpet
with my manager Streeter say what's up
shooter so this episode a lot of our
season takes place at like big events
for Chase and this is kind of the first
one of those where we had to like
produce a movie premiere and then we
shot our episode at it was you just
wanted it to be legitimate yeah I wanted
to help legitimize chase and the world
that these two doof's are entering you
know how like in real life you're gay
yes well it guys love that in fact one
of the guys wanted me to tell you that
his brother is also gay cool they think
that the character is straight more than
twelve years ago I went in for an
audition I don't even know what it was
for but all I had to do I didn't have
any lines I just had to pantomime like
laying fertiliser I just had to like
mime laying fertiliser and say no lines
and then when I was done they were like
that was great that was great so I think
you know this is sort of like a suburban
guy I think he's why so I just want to
try it again like a little more like
basically saying a little straighter
yeah without saying it and I was like
how do I'm I'm laying fertiliser
straighter though I can see was probably
pretty gay so I was like what do I do so
then I just did it again but I was sort
of like and I just like captain cleared
my throat I was like I guess a straight
person would like cough more all they
did it and then I got it and I've been
in those commercials for years like it's
played for comedy that you had to
reshoot this audition and do it less gay
yeah then at the very end where you feel
guilty that you allowed yourself to do
that yeah you kind of see like Carrie
sort of like dealing with internalized
homophobia at the end with with the
waiter being like he's he's like oh no
no for me it was just you know they
wanted it loud yeah you know and like
I've dealt with that in real life you
know were you
like yourself Haiti you know being a
queer actor you're like trying to you
get navigate this world and it's like a
very difficult area that you make
missteps in and it's like it's like what
do other people want you to be but then
regardless of what they want like will I
allow myself to change yeah what I think
people want I feel for Carrie I feel
like to talk about your character you
know I feel for Carrie but it's like you
know it's it he's if I got tough you
know because you're like oh I need this
money totally I'm gonna like throw
myself out the window no I like that it
never occurred to him when his agent was
like do it again less gay he's like okay
that's what you got to do and then
you're like oh oh oh it's yeah rough
hate sims's plays Brillon we really
going into casting couldn't tell if we
should cast young and make them look
older or cast older and just be like
they're 11 didn't know what was gonna
work immediately Kate made me laugh so
hard it was so hard to keep it straight
face when she was going into like
bursting into tears about my dad yeah
yeah yeah and her face was just so like
she was so deeply and and and even in
between Kate takes like Kate is such a
sweet person yes that the whole picture
was just unbelievable yeah because the
idea of that character is like very
broad or almost sketchy so we were
trying to make sure it's still grounded
but she was so good and uh like so funny
but still real even though it was so
preposterous yeah she's great
I left her Brooke thank God his party is
not fun
yes it is I'm having fun this episode
also has my favorite unspoken joke in it
which is you get drinks for you and
Carrie and you guys meet back together
and you give him the little mark Pink
Martini which is what Chris and I do and
we often order those things and then get
delivered them oppositely silently
switch
great party you this is a great party
glad you having fun man oh no no I'm I'm
auditioning for commercial funding about
that far commercial is this is the third
time it's been written because we tried
it twice at SNL as a sketch yeah we
tried it once with Paul Rudd and once
with Julia Louie Dreyfus it went really
well at the table then at dress
rehearsal it ate because the whole
sketch was predicated on him making very
small like fart smells right it's very
like subtle and small and just like a
huge audience like you're not gonna it's
not gonna work
yeah and then we were like well we'll
try it again with Julia Louie Dreyfus
and it got full it didn't work again and
we were like you know what you know this
was missing
[Music]
you